Hello everybody!
Oh my- I am tired.
Oh my gosh.
Hello.
I just want you guys to know, um, when I, uh, for when this was all over, um, yesterday, I think I slept like 18 hours.
I
was like awake and then I like fell back asleep.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, guys.
Okay, this is so embarrassing.
Okay.
Today I was still really tired.
I think it's because like everything just came crashing down on me.
Like, I was just like, you know, I was like using reserve energy to do everything until Restituber was over.
And then I actually started acting.
I started hibernating.
Okay, I'm gonna tell you guys a very embarrassing story.
It's not even a story.
It's not even a story, but it's so embarrassing.
It's a little TMI.
I'll just- But we're homies.
But like, guys, I just need you guys to know, this is a very embarrassing thing I'm gonna tell you guys.
But like, I have to let you guys know how tired I was.
So I'm just gonna give you guys a word.
Just so- Please do not laugh at me.
You guys are- No, reg- Nevermind.
You guys will laugh at me regardless.
You know, it's okay.
If you guys are gonna laugh at me, it's fine.
I understand why.
Anyway, this is how tired I was.
I woke up today.
I woke up.
I was like, alright.
Like, I- Yesterday I didn't even eat dinner.
That's how- Yesterday I- That's not the embarrassing part yet.
I was so tired from everything that I didn't even eat dinner yesterday.
I just like went to sleep.
I just- I- I just went to sleep before dinner yesterday.
And then I woke up.
And then I was like, okay, oh, I should get something to eat.
Like, oh my gosh.
It's- I don't remember what time I woke up.
I just know like, it's morning.
It's the day after.
It's today.
It's morning.
And then I was like, oh man.
I'm so- I should get some- I wasn't really hungry at that time.
But I was like, I should get something to eat.
Cause I didn't have dinner.
I might as well eat like brunch or something.
And so, I went to the bathroom.
And I went back to bed.
Because I used up all my energy.
And I- and I fell asleep.
I was like, okay, but first I really need to use the bathroom.
And after I finished using the bathroom, I went back to bed.
I was like, oh my gosh.
I'm so tired from all that energy.
I used up all my energy.
I was so- I was so- I felt fucking so tired.
I was like, I'm gonna go to sleep.
And then I woke up at like- I think I woke up at like 2pm.
I-
That's - that's how tired- that's how tired I was.
Oh yeah, I really wore myself there.
Mmm.
Um.
Um, but I just- that's how- that's when you know I was- I was very tired.
I still am.
I'm pretty sure after this stream I'm gonna go take a nap again just to like recharge my battery.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Cosmic, thank you for the super chat.
Oh, I'm not gonna read that message Cosmic.
But thank you.
Um.
I think it was a success.
I think WrestleTuber was- was a huge success.
Well, I don't know if I should say huge success.
But I think WrestleTuber did do- did like- do a good job.
Oh my gosh, sorry, my brain is like processing words.
I can't words right now.
But I think like WrestleTuber did go as how I wanted and beyond that because it feels like I think you guys all enjoyed it.
I think you guys, every single one of you guys enjoyed WrestleTuber and like all the nice surprises and everything.
And it just felt like and then having like so many different storylines.
So many different storylines being played out and all the...
You do know all of it was like AI, right?
Like everything was controlled by AI like the the wrestlers, but holy shit.
I don't know how but like...
I don't know how we were so lucky with the AI like where it went.
Because some of you guys were like, oh Joki, you purposely made Yuuzhan's wrestler overpowered as hell.
So like Beto was gonna lose no matter what.
No, actually, I wasn't... I... I...
It was the same.
I told them to make it the same stat.
I was like it has to be the same as everybody else.
So I have no idea how the fuck Beto got smacked so hard that he died outside.
of the ring like It's so fucking fast.
Like that surprised me as so much because I was definitely not expecting that.
To the point where he literally...
Like I think his AI actually died.
Like he just stopped moving.
And then I was like there's no way.
There's no way.
Get up!
Beto, get the fuck up!
That was...
That was fucking crazy.
I couldn't believe that happened.
It was like...
It was so perfect.
Beto was tired.
It was...
It was Beto's turn to be EP.
But yeah, both Yuuzhan and Beto are getting better.
They're getting belts sent over.
It was originally planned because people were like...
No!
Beto lost his belt!
It's not fair!
It's not fair baby.
Welcome to WWE.
It was never fair.
Well, listen.
People were saying like...
Oh my god.
It gave like John Cena versus...
What's his name?
The guy that plays Drax.
Guardians of the Galaxy.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna fucking butcher his name.
Guardians and...
Guardians of the Galaxy.
Batista.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
People were saying...
No, it's just like the John Cena versus Batista match.
All over again.
And like...
True.
Nope.
I'll show you guys the clip.
It's literally basically what happened.
What I did to...
What I did to Beto...
Is basically...
What happened in WWE.
It was...
Almost the same thing.
I'm basically...
The CEO...
Of WrestleTuber.
But like the one that...
The type of CEO that doesn't get arrested.
Not like...
Not like the WWE.
I would not like to be compared to the CEO...
To the ex-CEO.
Of WWE.
Because he got arrested for things.
And I am...
Not that type.
Too soon.
Bro, that happened in January.
That was like fucking sick.
Almost six months ago, guys.
It's not too soon.
Nam, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The best part for me...
Alongside seeing the Fable, Doki and Mint collab...
Was being introduced to so many new people.
I went from not knowing Nana to joining her membership.
And that's just one example.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, I think that's why I really wanted...
To do these types of...
Events.
Because like this is what we're missing.
In the...
In the NA...
Not just NA, but I would say...
We had Europeans joining WrestleTuber.
And also not just Europeans.
But also people from Asia joining...
People from Asia joining WrestleTuber.
But I feel like this is what we're missing...
In the English side.
In the Western VTuber scene.
With events that unite...
Different companies...
Different fan bases...
Indies, corporate...
Sorry.
I choked on water a little earlier.
But I muted so you guys didn't know.
But indies, corporate and everything...
Just smaller channels...
And big channels...
Working together in a very fun event.
And I felt like that was something we were missing.
We were missing that in the...
Western side of VTubing.
And this was something I've always wanted to do.
It has always been on my roadmap to have something that was open to...
Different companies.
And I was really happy to be able to do it.
And I was really happy I was able to...
Plan something like this.
Um...
And being able to...
Invite so many people...
Joining in as well.
I reached out to a lot of people.
Sending invites out.
And I didn't really...
And I wanted...
Different...
Even though there might be small VTubers...
I always wanted them to have a chance.
Especially with like...
Xprism.
I was happy to invite them over.
I think like Xprism was like...
The first group of people I invited.
To WrestleTuber.
They were the first invites I sent out.
I'm pretty sure.
And from there I sent out invites to all the other companies.
And also the indies as well.
Uh...
Thank you!
Congratulations!
On your first big event!
Sounds like you're working so hard.
Thank you!
Uh...
Next week I'm definitely gonna...
Chill next week.
Most likely I will have a rest week.
For next week.
So...
Because this week I couldn't really chill yet.
Uh...
Because I did have like prior obligations.
That I had to do.
Especially with the rest stuff.
Because the rest thing is ending on the 31st.
And I felt bad because they invited me.
It's a huge rest streaming server.
Like a lot of the big names are part of it.
And I got like the...
Invite to join.
And like there's not a lot of VTubers in there too.
So I thought it was like...
Oh this is such a rare invite to join the server.
So I was like... Oh fuck.
I should do at least one day.
I should try out...
I should try...
Yeah the rest kingdom.
I was like...
Oh man I should try at least one day.
There's always next week.
There isn't though.
That's the thing.
The rest server is ending like literally in three days.
So...
It's ending on the 31st.
So I was like...
Oh man I need to do at least one day.
Okay.
Just check it out.
Thank you for the Aka Aka soup again.
Thank you.
Um...
And...
Oh my gosh.
Okay for behind the scenes stuff.
I want to say a huge shout out to the people I contacted.
To make the secret wrestlers.
Because like...
For like Bettle2.
Mint, Matara.
And Yuusan.
Huge shout out to the two...
The two people I contacted.
Let me see.
I didn't put them on the credits.
Because I forgot to ask the graphics people to put them on the...
To put them on the credits page.
But it was...
Sir Wheat...
Sir Wheatbread and...
Snakehisshiss.
They both made the secret wrestlers.
For...
For all of them.
So huge shout out to them.
For making the wrestlers.
Um...
What else?
I was like...
Keep it secret.
Don't tell anybody.
No one can know.
They are going to appear.
It has to be secret.
To be fair.
The Mint and Matara...
The Mint and Matara wrestlers...
Were super last minute.
Like literally a day...
A day before they debuted.
And so like...
Huge shout out for them to...
To make those...
To make the wrestlers.
Because they are literally like...
I literally asked them the day before...
The day before they like...
Appeared on stream.
Um...
Matara was the day before.
She appeared on stream.
And then Mint was like...
The day before the first day.
The day before the first... like Saturday basically.
They finished it on Friday.
So yeah.
Huge shout out...
To them for making those wrestlers...
At the last minute.
Oh my gosh.
My voice is slowly dying.
And yeah.
NDA is like...
Trust me.
Source me.
That's the NDA.
Don't leak.
Source me.
I'm not...
If they leak it, then I would know.
Because I literally told them.
They were the only people I told.
So like...
Because even people in the server didn't know...
Until the day of...
The event.
So like...
I did say there might be...
Surprised guests.
But they didn't know until...
The day of the event started.
So like...
Yousan got invited to the server on Sunday.
Like on Sunday...
Before we started the stream.
And like, Mint also.
Mint got invited to the server on Saturday.
I think like an hour before the stream started.
So like, I kept that secret.
Also, Beto too as well.
Like I kept all the guest appearances a secret until the day of.
So like, if it was leaked, then I would know who leaked it.
I would know exactly who leaked it.
Because I told a very limited amount of people.
Yes, Beto too joined the server like...
Like an hour before Saturday.
So like an hour before the stream for Saturday started.
So like, they were all like a secret.
So a huge shout out to Beto for letting me invite Beto too.
I was like, hey, I didn't realize Beto too was like a real person.
Like, are you okay?
Like, do you want to play?
I was like, are you okay with inviting your twin over?
And he was like, so...
You know, she was like, yo, that's me so funny.
Like, yeah, let's do it.
I was like, don't worry about making a Beto too.
Buy WWE 2K24 because I know it's very expensive.
Don't worry, I'll get somebody to make him.
So yeah, even the videos.
The videos, like the surprise appearances with Mint and Matara.
Those were done like the day of.
Like the day they were going to appear.
The videos were shown.
That my video editor, shout out to my video editor.
They like made it the day of...
The day of their appearance too.
Because I had the idea and I was like, can you make it?
And they're like, oh yeah.
They're like, are you sure?
And they're like, yeah, yeah, yeah, we can make it.
We can do it.
So huge, huge shout out to my team.
By the way, for those who don't know.
This whole event was practically almost solely ran by me.
Including me running the OBS and everything.
Because I wanted to see if I could do it.
And then I also wanted to see like, okay, like...
How should this be ran?
Like how should this be done in a way?
So like I think like next year.
When I do WrestleTuber 2025 again.
I'm definitely going to give it to another person to run the OBS.
So that it's less scuffed.
But like now that I know how it should go.
Like at least I can like direct it better.
Like I can direct it better.
I can direct it in a better way.
In terms of like, oh okay.
I've done this before.
Then I know how like this should go.
Like how to do the scenes and everything.
How to do the swaps.
Especially when I'm running like new programs and stuff.
Where like...
With like guest caster and everything.
So like I'm just figuring stuff out on how the whole stream was going to be like.
So like now that I know how to do it myself.
Then like me telling someone else to do it.
And like controlling it.
I feel like it would be definitely easier.
Because I have the better...
Like I know how it can be done.
So like you know.
Instead of like putting images on live.
Like...
Like you're like who's next.
And then there's like a fucking giant picture.
That's like...
That's like leaking out to other scenes.
And then have to like resize it live.
That's not going to happen.
For next year.
For next year it's not...
We won't be resizing images live.
And everything.
So...
So at least like I have a better vision.
On how things are going to go.
And another shout out to all the people that created wrestlers.
For everybody.
For like all the other...
All the other participants.
Like I know it's a lot of work.
Because when people were creating it themselves.
Literally streams would be like 3 plus hours sometimes.
So like a huge shout out.
A huge shout out to the people who were creating.
The fans who were creating wrestlers for us as well.
And also like making them so accurate.
To the character.
To like the VTubers.
Because whoever fucking made the Fillion.
The Fillion wrestler.
And made that wrestler flip like 200,000 times.
That was so accurate.
I was just like...
I was just like watch the Fillion.
I feel like Fillion's wrestler.
Was honestly one of the most memorable for me.
Because all she did was flip.
She would flip like 200,000...
Fucking thousand times.
That's all she would do.
It was just...
It was so accurate.
I couldn't believe how accurate this was.
She was so fucking fast.
She would flip and dance.
Yeah.
So...
Huge shout out to everybody that made a wrestler.
And like made it so accurate to the actual person.
It was actually crazy.
Oh yeah.
Before I talk more about WrestleTuber.
I also really want to talk about Anime North.
Okay so like...
I'll talk about...
I talked about this during the panel.
So those who were there at Anime North will remember what I said then.
But like...
I almost like had a panic attack before...
Before like it started.
Because...
Because I thought there was only 10 people that had showed up.
So...
Okay.
So like...
So basically...
When it was like 10...
The staff was like...
Oh...
We're gonna let people in now.
And I was like...
Okay.
And then literally only 10 people walked in.
I was like...
Oh...
That was just like...
I was like...
Oh...
I mean...
I guess...
And then...
And then I waited.
I was like...
Oh maybe...
Maybe like...
You know...
People didn't...
Only 10 people were there early.
And then...
And then I...
And then I was just like...
Okay that's okay Doki.
Yeah.
You're so silly Doki.
When you think there's that many people that are gonna see you.
And then...
And then like...
Literally like...
3 minutes later...
More people started showing up.
But then it went from 10...
To like...
30.
So I was like...
Oh that's a lot better.
I was just like...
Oh...
That's...
That's a lot better.
30 people is a lot better.
And then literally on...
At the...
At 8.30...
EST...
Cause it was like EST...
Like Eastern Time.
Like...
When the panel was about to...
Like was supposed to start.
Suddenly like 600 people started...
Fucking getting into the room.
And I was like...
Holy fuck.
I was just...
I was just like...
Oh my god.
I was like...
What happened?
Were all of you just late?
I was so surprised.
I was like...
600...
Cause like the maximum amount was 600.
Um...
So then I was like...
Were all of you just fucking late?
Like what the fuck happened?
But apparently people...
There was a lot of people outside.
And like...
Um...
Apparently staff had to give like...
Tickets or something.
To like make sure...
You guys don't go above the fire hazard.
Uh...
Like...
Um...
So like there were a lot of people actually lining up.
But then they had to give like wristbands or something.
So that's why people were...
Um...
They couldn't let everybody in right away.
Because they all had to get wristbanded.
So like when...
When...
When everybody like 600 people got wristbanded.
They let them in.
So they let them in at exactly 830.
So I was so...
I was...
I was like so sad.
Cause I was like...
Oh man.
I was thinking...
Maybe...
Maybe I should do less conventions.
Cause I was like...
You know...
30 people.
Like I feel so bad.
Cause they're paying...
They're paying me to be here at these conventions too.
So I was like...
Oh man.
If I only brought 30 people.
I'm so...
I'll be...
I feel bad.
I'm so...
I feel...
I made them pay...
I made them pay so much money for me to be here.
And then...
And then 600 dragoons showed up.
And I was like...
Oh thank god.
My price was just...
I'm joking.
I don't charge that much.
But like...
But also in my mind I was like...
Oh thank god.
Okay.
I did not...
Like...
What's the word?
I was not too expensive.
It was justified.
For how much I charge to be here.
Yeah.
Not a scammer.
Not a scammer because I over...
Like I filled the entire hall.
Apparently a lot of people wanted to still be there.
But of course...
Like I said...
Like...
Because...
We couldn't have that much at the convention.
I have more than 600 people because of fire safety.
So apparently we did have to turn people away.
But do not worry!
There's gonna be a lot of other conventions.
For the Joki World Tour.
So don't worry guys.
I had to sneeze.
Sorry, I'm okay now.
I had to sneeze and blow my nose.
Thank you, I really appreciate it.
But yes!
Thank you everybody for showing up to Anime North.
I really do appreciate it.
The very first convention I did...
I did as Dohia.
And being able to do a Canadian convention was great.
I've never done a Canadian convention before.
So I was really happy to be able to visit people at Anime North and do a panel.
Apparently a lot of people had a lot of fun at the panel.
That's great.
I told some stories that I couldn't tell on stream.
So...
If you were there, you would know exactly why I can't tell that story on stream.
So they got some exclusive stories.
Just for panels.
What exactly?
Should have been in Toronto, bro.
Should have been in Toronto.
Should have been there.
I have exclusive convention stories that I cannot tell on stream.
Because it's a little spicy.
Spicy as in like controversial.
Actual paywall.
Welcome to member goons.
Now you know how the gray name feels.
Like...
Now...
Now you know how they feel.
Okay, it's not that controversial.
Okay, I might have like...
Maybe now...
Okay.
Okay, now I fucking sold...
Over-hyped it too much.
Like oversold that story.
It's not that controversial.
It's just that like...
It just...
I just...
I just shouldn't be a story I tell on stream.
Don't sit down to their level.
Now you need to tell...
No, I can't tell you guys.
Just like...
Just like ask some of the dragoons that were there.
Like ask the dragoons that were there what the story was on discord or something.
Or on social media.
But like...
I know you guys are gonna be like...
But it's not the same Doki.
It's not the same when...
Like it's not coming out of your mouth.
Well, too bad.
You should have been in Toronto.
What?
Just go to the other community.
I'll tell...
I'll retell the story at the other conventions.
And then you can be special too guys.
Um...
You can...
It's not the same.
We have so many conventions guys.
Just show up at any of the other conventions.
Don't worry.
It's not just gonna be in Canada guys.
It's the world tour.
And the world...
It consists more than just Canada.
So like...
You go to the...
Atua Fae Wall.
What?
They have to get there?
They have to get their money's worth guys.
The conventions have to get their money's worth.
Um...
So I'll retell that story in the other conventions.
You just have to make sure when we're at the panel for Q&A.
And you go there and be like...
Can you tell us your Fae Wall stories?
You have to...
I won't tell the story unless like I'm giving the question.
Regarding like the Fae Wall story.
So like if you've never heard the convention Fae Wall story.
Just make sure.
We go to whatever convention I'm gonna show up.
And then you'll be like...
Doki!
Can you like tell us that story?
That you exclusively Fae Walled for just conventions?
And then I'll tell you the story.
I'll tell you...
And then...
And then you can be part of the special club.
You can be part of the special exclusive story club.
That you would know.
And you'll be like...
I know the special story.
Damn Collins Fae Walled Satch.
What if she keeps making up the...
Making a new Fae...
Oh yeah.
Each convention I go to.
I tell a very exclusive story.
So like it's like...
You know how like at conventions you collect t-shirts and stuff.
So as like a memorabilia for the convention.
So like for the Doki memorabilia.
It's like each convention.
You collect exclusive convention story.
The fear...
No my fault.
Each convention you change the story a little bit.
Oh don't give me ideas guys.
Don't...
Just like...
Yay.
Oh.
Don't give me some beautiful brilliant ideas chat.
The follow is hitting me hard.
We just locked and Fae Walled is real.
But are they giving us a super chat?
Thank you.
I need the full collection!
NOOO!
Gladstone.
The story involve a certain outfit by any chance.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'll I guess...
Guess you gotta find out in the next convention.
When you...
When you ask me that...
When you ask for a Fae walled story.
Guess you gotta...
You gotta go to the next convention to find out.
But thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
This message is region locked.
Please visit Hong Kong to view this message.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Alright.
Um...
But yeah, anyway.
Had a great time at Anime North.
The hour really passed by so fast.
It just felt like had a really great time just like talking to the dragoons there.
And um...
We had one...
Okay, I can talk about this guy.
Cause like he literally is not even a dragoon.
Like he... There's this one guy that managed to get to the Q&A part because a lot of people wanted to ask me questions, yeah?
And we had an hour.
So like one of the guy... One of the guys that was in the fucking line did not even know who I was.
Like he just went to the...
He literally just went to the panel cause a lot of people were there.
So he was like, I'm gonna go to this panel.
Because so many other people were lining up.
And then he got picked for a question.
And he was like in the Q&A, he was like I don't know who you are.
But like I saw a lot of people lining up so I came along and I was like, wait are you serious?
And he was like, yeah I don't...
I don't even know what question he asked.
He just was like, I don't know who you are.
And like, but I called him out.
I called him out and I was like Bro, you literally took this spot from...
You literally took this spot from somebody who wanted to ask a question.
And he's like, well I guess so.
Bro, like I don't even...
Like when he said that it actually like blew my mind that I don't even remember what he asked of me.
Like I don't even remember what kind of question he asked.
He just...
He actually went up to the line just to be like, I don't know who you are.
Boo.
Like it was actually crazy.
I was like, how do you...
Why did you...
Why did you come up to line?
You were this guy's side mission.
Thank you Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
Oh yeah, yeah.
I was like this guy's random side mission.
This is like, visit a anime girl Q&A.
Q &A.
Um...
Anyway, I'll talk about WrestleTuber!
WrestleTuber.
Oh my gosh.
It was so much...
It was so much work.
Oh, DarkBlade!
Yeah, I messed up DarkBlade's name cause like he said...
I thought he said Darkwing.
I was like, wait I remember seeing Darkwing on chat.
I was like, yeah I know a Darkwing.
And he's like, no Darkblade.
And I was like, oh I also know a Darkblade.
Yeah.
I was like, wait I also know a Darkblade too!
Um, but yes, thank you Super Chat Darkblade.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm gonna introduce myself to Doki and she got my name wrong.
I didn't get your name wrong the first time.
You just weren't loud enough so I like thought I heard Darkwing and he exists.
Okay, Darkwing exists.
He also exists, Darkblade.
You can't just claim all the Dark names, man.
He's real to me.
They all exist, guys.
Where?
There he is!
Do you not see him?
See, there he is!
There's Darkwing!
See, he said hi!
I can't believe you ignored Darkwing over there.
He's literally there.
Uh, anyway guys.
Um...
WrestleTuber...
Oh my god.
It was so much work.
Like, uh, just setting...
I got a lot of assets and stuff like...
the day before.
And like, um, so like for the...
uh, like literally the last...
four... the four hours before... the four hours before my Apex tournament...
um, I was just like putting all the... like putting all the...
OBS stuff...
together.
And like putting...
like just putting everything together...
that last minute.
Um, because I got all my assets the day before.
And I was so tired.
I was originally gonna take a nap and then like...
uh, do everything and then take another nap...
before the tournament.
But I ended up sleeping.
I ended up...
I ended up sleeping so late.
I think like three to four hours...
before the actual...
uh, actual like the Apex tournament.
I was just compiling everything.
As fast as I can.
And then...
an hour before... um...
an hour before the... like you know...
after the Apex tournament was over...
I had to still set up stuff...
for the WrestleTuber things.
And I'm like...
Oh my god!
Why did I...
decided like, you know... I was like...
regretting the choice of...
uh... the choice of...
doing everything myself at that...
moment.
I was like... Why?
Why did I do all this myself?
Why?
I was like...
I was like... Oh my god...
Doki, you're so fucking stupid!
Why did you ask for help?
Why are you doing...
this yourself, Doki?
You can literally ask...
people to help you!
And... but then... it was all okay.
It went... it went okay guys.
Everything was okay.
Okay guys!
Oh...
past Doki...
That's something I'm definitely... like I said...
for WrestleTuber 2025...
I'm definitely gonna like... have...
someone else handle the OPS stuff.
Um... handling the scenes...
and everything.
Making sure like...
all the scene stuff is running...
okay instead of me...
you know... putting everything together.
Yes!
It was me running the chat!
I ran the chat polls too!
I ran the chat polls!
I handled the OPS!
I told the commentators who's gonna be fighting next.
I was like... the cast...
I was like directing everything.
Um...
I put all the graphics together.
I told... I like... told...
Like guided everything.
Scheduled everything.
It was all me.
Everything.
And also like...
all the other people that helped too.
Uh... we know because of Charlie.
Yeah that... that Charlie thing...
was so fucking funny.
Cause like... but then it was like...
Wait who's next?
And then I literally just wrote...
Charlie vs Octavio.
And like... cause I was like... there's no way...
that she actually doesn't know who Beto is.
There's no...
I was like... there's no way...
The guest... the list... the participant list...
and the bracket...
was all there.
Like...
I wrote it down.
Then I just decided to test her.
I was... I don't know.
I just wanted to test her to see...
to see if like... you know...
If she really knew who...
who Beto is.
It was funny though.
It was pretty funny that I actually...
I got away with that.
That was...
hilarious.
No it was just fucking funny.
So funny.
She not pass.
I mean...
It's funny to just fuck with people sometimes.
You know?
But yeah...
Things I would do differently...
for WrestleTuber...
I think...
I don't know.
I don't know honestly.
I don't know...
Cause like I know...
Like I was thinking...
Maybe people should fight...
You know... Instead of just straight off single elimination...
There should be a double elimination.
But I felt like the reason why I don't want to do a double elimination...
Which means like...
If you get knocked out the first time...
You get to fight again in the losers bracket.
But the reason why I don't want to...
do a double elimination...
Was because it's a lot of time.
Because like single...
Single elimination is already...
Like two days.
You know?
We already have...
Like it already was a long time...
For two days.
So that's why I don't think I want to...
Yeah that would just take way too long.
And...
I feel like two days is like...
The perfect amount of days.
And like because of that...
I feel like...
I like the amount of people we got.
Like 20... What was it?
Well to be fair we had a lot of surprise wrestlers.
So I guess it would be like...
Was it 33 wrestlers?
I think it was like an okay amount...
To have for...
For it.
Darkwing thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you!
See I told you!
I was not going crazy!
Darkwing was real!
You guys did not believe me!
Darkwing is real!
They said hi earlier.
You didn't see it.
You had to make that man...
Super chat.
So like he could exist for you guys.
That's so fucked up.
Like he only exists for you guys when he donates.
That's so messed up.
Dragoons.
He's a real person.
He's not just money.
He's a fucking real Dragoon.
It's messed up that it only took him to super chat for you guys to acknowledge his existence.
Like I think...
Darkwing you didn't have to donate.
You didn't have to donate.
To make them notice you.
I already saw you with my eyes.
Sir Weepred.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Spend a week to use different types of matches.
Like casting match and steel cage.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I feel like for that.
I feel like that's what show matches are for.
I still want to keep the tournament format.
I like that someone was trying to do like...
Tag team.
I like that idea.
A tag team tournament.
I don't know if...
Can...
Can like...
WWE 2K24 do that?
Is there like tag team tournaments that we could do?
That's not like...
Because if we can...
Then I think a tag team tournament...
Would be really fun too in the future.
I don't know if that would be a thing for next year.
But like I do like that idea.
I do like that idea.
And I think it would be fun.
If it's like mixed as well.
Like you spin the wheel to random teammates.
So that like...
You know people can...
Form friendships over that.
Because a really fun thing about it.
Is just seeing all the friendships being formed as well.
Like seeing...
Seeing like people who normally don't interact with each other.
Suddenly being like...
Really close friends.
Just from WrestleTuber.
Like we are like...
I really saw like so many friendships being formed.
From other VTubers.
And just like...
People are now like close friends.
And they are like...
Following each other and hanging out and stuff like that.
And I thought it was like...
Really nice to see.
It was really nice to see from WrestleTuber.
Ummm...
And like other VTubers.
Getting to know other VTubers.
And like the...
The integration...
Between like Twitch viewers.
And corporate viewers.
And indie viewers.
Just coming together.
For one big event.
Ummm...
It's been like super fun to see.
Uhhh...
I don't know what other changes I'll make.
To the WrestleTuber format.
Ummm...
I think like usually...
Like as usual.
I might have like an open call.
To see like...
Because like...
All the participants.
Ummm...
In WrestleTuber.
Like I specifically reached out to.
Ummm...
And asked if they want to join.
And I think like...
Obviously I don't know a lot of...
Some of them were like...
I asked like...
I wanted to invite some indies.
I don't really know a lot of the indie community in VTubing.
Because I was like...
You know...
I wasn't part of that circle.
For like...
I wasn't really part of that circle before.
So like I didn't really know who were like big indies.
And who were like well known indies.
Ummm...
In the community.
So I did ask like some people like...
Oh if you have any recommendations.
Feel free to recommend me some indie VTubers.
You would like to bring along as well.
Like I would send the invite.
Be like if you have any recommendations.
Ummm... Like feel free to.
Send in like...
People you want to join.
And I think like in the future.
I would love to like...
I guess like be like...
Hey guys...
If you make an open call I guess on Twitter.
And be like...
If you want to join WrestleTuber 2025.
Just please like you know...
Just throw your comment in.
So I can like...
Maybe you might get picked.
It would definitely be a lot easier.
It definitely would be a lot easier.
To do.
And so me reaching out to people.
And like aligning schedules and stuff like that.
Well if it's just like comments.
I can just like send a DM.
After like looking through the comments and stuff.
But like I do want to keep it like...
Like I guess like my max cutoff.
Would be 30.
That would be my max cutoff.
Because like 2 days was...
I think 2 days is the most optimal.
You know like...
I like how...
I do like that I...
It be my very first wrestling event.
That I've ever organized.
As DokiBraid.
We didn't keep...
We kept the...
The interviews and stuff.
Not that long.
We tried to make sure the interviews did not look like...
Last too long.
Because I wasn't sure how long the matches were going to be.
So I tried to make sure like...
The interview portion didn't last too long.
Um...
So I did like that.
As like a thing I did for this...
This year.
Um...
Uh...
It would be interesting to see what happens for next year.
Perk...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What about Hell in a Cell tournament match?
WrestleTuber was amazing Doki.
Hope to see more in the future.
Um... I'm not sure yet.
I don't know if I want to...
Uh... deviate from the regular...
One on one.
Um... If anything I think I would love to do like...
Tag team.
Um... If I do want to deviate...
And change something...
Change something for the format.
In terms of like the tournament format.
I think like tag team would be like...
Really fun to do.
Just cause it's like...
You know... 2v2 tag team.
Or like... like you know... like tag each other out.
And stuff.
I think that would be like...
Really fun.
Um... a really fun...
Tournament idea.
Because like you know...
There's more friendships being made from that.
Hmm...
Um...
But we'll see.
We'll see what the...
Storyline will be next year.
Uh...
We'll see what it's gonna be like.
Um... alright.
The thing that everybody wants to know...
Like...
Always keep... cause like I think...
Um... this is gonna be a short stream guys.
I am still...
Very exhausted.
Like... I'm still...
I am like...
Really tired.
So like... I'm really sorry I can't do...
A super long stream today.
Uh... for like the after party.
I really...
Okay... the reason... I really wanted to do the after party.
After the...
Uh... WrestleTuber.
Uh... the WrestleTuber event was over.
Cause usually after every event...
I would do an after party.
But um...
I got caught... uh...
What's the word?
Uh... I think like Mintory told it already.
But like basically what happened was that...
Mint and I ended up talking for 4 plus hours.
Last night... no not last night.
The night before.
Hahaha...
I lost track of time.
And we ended up just like...
Catching up and talking for...
Uh... 4 hours.
Um... so I couldn't do... I didn't do the after party.
And um...
Like I said... usually...
I know this is the story...
That everybody wants to hear.
Like...
For all you guys that's tapped out right now...
This is it guys.
You can tap back in now to hear the story.
Hahaha...
Um...
Anyway...
So um... a lot of you guys were wondering like...
Oh... like was Mint a last minute addition?
Yes...
Uh... she is.
Um... um... so...
I think like I sort of like...
I saw like what Mint said.
So I wanted to make sure like...
I said like similar stuff so that like...
I don't like...
Like you know...
I just say like what she said already.
Um... and add a little bit of info...
Behind the scenes.
Um...
Basically...
Oh my gosh I'm nervous now.
Hahaha...
Your nervousness is coming to me...
Even though it's my story.
Hahaha...
It's like my story...
And now you guys are making me nervous telling it.
Hahaha...
Um...
Anyway...
So um... like I said...
Um... we only recently...
Uh...
Got... were able to...
Talk again.
Um... uh... so...
I saw... like I'm just like remembering what she said.
So I gotta make sure like...
It says something.
Um... and um...
Um...
Uh...
She was the one that...
Sorry if there's like pauses cause I have to think about what I'm saying.
Hahaha...
Basically she was the one...
That initiated first.
Um... and I really appreciate that.
Because I think...
Uh... I told her...
I was like... I didn't... like...
If she never initiated...
I don't think I would have...
Uh... I don't think like...
We would have ever talked.
Um... if she never initiated.
Cause I would... I was never going to...
Uh... I was never going to initiate first.
Um... so...
She was the one that...
Uh...
Um...
She was the one that initiated first.
By following me on Twitter.
And... uh...
I saw that she followed me on Twitter.
And so...
From there I followed her back.
And... um...
From that...
My management team noticed...
That we were following each other again.
So...
One of my staff members...
In my management team...
Actually sent an email out...
To Mint.
Asking if...
Uh... she wanted to join WrestleTuber.
Um...
Cause it was already announced.
And I guess you guys can get the timeline of everything.
Cause people who could see...
Like how...
When we followed each other.
And... uh...
From there... my management team...
And then Mint responded back.
And my management team...
One of my staff members...
Gave her my Discord.
And then we connected back from there.
And... like... you know...
We talked a lot...
Like in Discord.
And then from there...
We had like a 4 hour...
After WrestleTuber...
We had a 4 hour...
Chatting and reconnecting and everything.
Um...
That was really nice.
It was very...
I guess therapeutic to say.
It was very therapeutic to be able to talk to her again.
Um...
Because I know like...
There was a lot of questions regarding this.
But... um...
I never got a chance to say goodbye.
Um... so like...
That's why I never...
Reached out to her.
Um... and...
Because I didn't know where I was at.
For a lot of things.
So like... I didn't want to intrude.
Or like... I didn't know where I was.
Um...
For it.
So that's why... uh...
That's why I told her.
I was like...
If you never initiated...
I would have never like...
Tried anything.
Because it was more so of like...
Oh... um...
Um... I didn't...
I just didn't... I was scared.
Hahaha...
I was just really...
I just didn't know where I was at.
So that's why... uh...
I really appreciate that she like...
Uh... took the first step.
You know?
And... uh...
And then some people were asking...
Um... was Matara also...
Last minute?
Yes, she was...
Last minute as well.
Uh... it was... we... I asked Mint...
Uh... after the first day was over.
I asked Mint...
I was like... hey... like... you know...
Do you want to fight Matara?
Like does Matara want to join?
You know?
Like... because I was like... we do have like... two spots.
Here.
Like you know... like the...
Hahaha... like because I like...
I realized... oh shit wait... we have like...
two spots.
I did my math wrong.
With the brackets.
And like... you know...
I was like... oh shit... I forgot.
We have like that section.
You know... missing.
And then usually... like I was thinking...
Like oh okay... we'll just like grab somebody.
We'll just like grab somebody...
Who's like... who got eliminated early on.
And...
Who got eliminated early on and then put like...
Put them back in.
But then I was one...
I was like thinking... you know... like I think... you know...
Mint and Matara fighting... like...
Hahaha... I don't know.
The Mint and Matara fight... I feel like...
People would really want to see it.
So I asked Mint if like Matara was down.
And Matara said that she was down.
Even though like... you know... she was on vacation.
She would love to be part of the...
Mint versus...
Like Matara fight.
The hag fight.
Hag fight!
Hahaha...
Sweet thank you for the agenda... super...
Thank you... thank you... um... and that's how...
Matara got involved into...
WrestleTuber.
And I really appreciate...
Matara for... uh... joining...
As well since... like I said she was on her vacation.
And I think she still did...
Oh no she came back.
I saw that she recently...
Was streaming... she's streaming today.
So...
Uh... she was on her vacation.
And so I really appreciate Matara sending in...
Like the voice lines and stuff.
And uh... shout out to my editor...
For making the...
The video 3 hours before the event!
Hahaha...
My editor...
Literally made the video...
3 to 4 hours before it was...
Like about to start.
So...
For day 2...
So like huge shout out to my editor...
For getting that done.
Um...
Cause I was like to my editor...
Can you do it?
I'm really sorry...
Like this is so last minute...
I was like I'm so sorry...
Like this is such a last minute edition...
And then we just got...
Like we just got the voice lines and stuff...
Um...
Like the morning of the day 2...
So... uh... so yeah like...
That's basically how Matara got involved.
Uh... Yuson...
Has been... has actually been invited...
For a while...
Uh... like I think it was like the day after...
The announcement...
Um... that Yuson was invited...
And that was always my plan because I thought it would be really fucking funny...
Cause I was just thinking about you know like...
Like Yuson coming in with the seal...
The fucking seal chair...
Like you know like...
I thought... I thought it was...
I thought it would be really funny...
And it was like... Yuson like messaged me...
Um... the day...
Cause like before then I was thinking keeping it...
Strictly to like...
Like NA participants...
Like NA EU participants for WrestleTuber...
Um...
But then like we had like you know the last minute editions...
With Holostars and stuff like that...
And like also a huge shoutout again to Axel...
For getting Holostars...
Um... into the event like...
Super last minute...
Um... literally...
Literally like two days before the...
I think two days before the announcement of the event...
Two or three days before the announcement of the event...
Axel...
Uh... got Holostars involved...
Um... so like there was a lot of things that were happening...
Last minute...
But I think like... I don't really...
I think like...
Uh...
I didn't think...
Um... it was like...
What's the word?
I don't think that...
Uh...
WrestleTuber would be as good as it was...
Without all of these last minute editions...
So it all worked out in the end...
Which was fucking insane...
Because usually when you do stuff last minute...
It doesn't work out in the end...
So...
So like...
Somehow everything just worked out...
Like I... like as a one man...
Army...
Somehow everything just worked out...
Um...
And...
Oh my gosh...
Yes like the Jibo and the Taka...
Guest casting and the guest announcement...
Oh and cute shout out to Taka...
For fucking jumping in last minute...
To do the announcement stuff...
Because Sayu was like... you know...
He had like issues on day one...
With like his own personal schedule...
Like something unexpectedly came up for day one...
So Taka coming in clutch...
And he was like...
I think like 30 minutes...
I think like an hour and 30 minutes...
Before the actual stream was about to start...
Like huge shout out to him...
For taking the announcer role there...
Um...
Oh yeah...
I didn't know if like...
Sayu said anything...
Regarding why he wasn't there...
But yes he had a flight cancelled...
Because I didn't want to say it...
Because I wasn't sure if he said why he wasn't there...
Because I didn't know if it was like a personal thing...
But yes he had a flight cancelled...
And that's why he couldn't make it for day one...
So like um...
It was awesome for Taka...
For to like do the...
Do the announcement stuff for us...
Um I really...
It was like clutch for everybody...
Like I said everybody that worked on this...
It was super clutch...
And I really appreciate everybody coming together...
And staying up and working on this...
Event with me...
And making all these memorable memories...
And stuff with everyone...
Um...
But yeah...
That's really how it all came to be...
In terms of everything...
Um...
And like...
I'm happy...
I'm really happy...
That everything just worked out...
In the end...
And like I'm happy that Mint reached out...
Like I said like...
Uh...
I said like to people who were like...
Oh why don't you talk to this person...
Why don't you talk to that person...
Like regarding like...
People I've used to...
Um might have talked to before...
Um I'm just letting them do the first step...
Because like...
I don't want to intrude on anything...
And I don't know like where I'm at...
At certain places...
So that...
That's why I'm not doing the first step...
When it comes to these things...
Um because I don't want to put anybody in like...
A weird position...
Uh for anything...
So like usually I'm just waiting for people to do the first step...
Like I...
Um if they...
If they extend their hand...
To me first...
Then um...
Then obviously I'll reciprocate...
Uh...
Hahaha...
So yeah...
That's basically how it is...
Hahaha...
Oh yes...
Tenjin...
I'm very excited for the collab tomorrow with Tenjin...
Um for those who were...
Uh...
Hahaha...
I'll tell Tenjin this tomorrow...
But like...
For those who were there for the story about Tarkov...
That was Tenjin...
Hahaha...
Um...
When I was talking about this fucker that still bought Tarkov after this drama...
Cause it was on sale...
That was...
That was Tenjin...
Hahaha...
Cause he was like bro but it's 50% off bro...
I'm like bro they just literally had a controversy...
He's like but it was 50% off...
No it was 80% off...
No you don't understand...
It's 80% off...
Hahaha...
Um...
So...
Yes he...
That was him...
I couldn't say it but now I can...
That it was Tenjin...
Bro...
He called me out on stream...
Cause like...
I like sent him a message on...
I sent him a message on Discord...
And he was like...
You fucker...
You bitch...
He called me out live on stream...
He was like you fuck...
He was like you fucking...
Cause I was lurking...
I didn't want to derail his stream...
I was literally lurking on his stream...
And then he fucking called me out...
Hahaha...
Um...
But yes...
I'm super excited for tomorrow...
With the Apex collab...
Uh...
With Tenjin...
He was actually supposed to be in my Nokia...
Invitational hide and seek...
But because like...
It was so last minute...
Cause I...
We had some issues with teammates...
Regarding the hide and seek stuff...
So like I had...
Four times I had to find substitute teammates...
Hahaha...
And...
Tenjin was originally...
Well it's not the original...
But he was one of the first substitutes...
He was the first substitute...
Um...
But like...
Because of like scheduling wise...
We had like issues with scheduling wise...
For like the OG teammates...
Um...
And...
Tenjin was the original...
But then because he lives in...
He lives in like Indonesia...
Uh...
I was like...
Hey my team...
This is my first choice sub...
Can you like send these things to Indonesia?
And they were like...
No...
Because customs...
Hahaha...
We don't know what the customs gonna be like...
We don't know if we get lucky with the customs...
Hahaha...
So he couldn't be...
He couldn't be a teammate...
Hahaha...
We didn't even know that the stuff wouldn't be there in time.
Did you guys know Nokia is really fucking good with like...
Wi-Fi stuff infrastructure?
Like that's the whole point of this Apex Invitational.
It's the test out there...
Like Wi-Fi.
Like their new Wi-Fi thing.
Because apparently Nokia is now instead of phones, they do like Wi-Fi infrastructure.
Yeah!
They...
They like apparently like...
Known for like Wi-Fi stuff now.
Hahaha...
I did not know that.
Um... so they're sending us... yeah, they're sending us like the... like I have one.
Like I haven't set it up yet.
Uh, we're supposed to learn how to set it up.
Okay, Apex over Wi... Yes!
Okay, I found out when I got invited.
Like... like... guys, I knew when I got invited because I had to research what... why we're receiving like Wi-Fi stuff.
Um...
But... but yes, anyway.
Um... they have to send out this pack.
This like care package which included the Wi-Fi tower... the Wi-Fi kit or whatever.
Um... and... uh... really?
So it is an app... Bro, it literally says sponsored by Nokia.
Like... I literally have Nokia on the schedule.
Damn right, it's sponsored by Nokia.
Damn right, it's like an advertisement.
Like...
Like the whole tournament is like to advertise their Wi-Fi shit.
Uh... yeah, he got physically... Tenjin got physically region locked out of the game.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh... Neil.
Um... but yes, uh... so that's why like... uh... Tenjin couldn't be the original substitute.
And I literally messaged...
Uh... Fun.
Um... I literally messaged Fun because I saw like... I know who's like...
Basically almost like all the pro players... not all the pro players but like pro players that are well known are in the hide and seek tournament.
This like... hide and seek tournament.
Um... because like...
Jen... I originally messaged Jen as one of the other substitutes but Jen was already taken.
Jen was like, fuck if you messaged me like an hour earlier I would have been your teammate.
Uh... Jen Burn by the way.
Um... because I messaged Jen Burn and literally he got swiped an hour before I messaged him.
So... I couldn't get Jen Burn.
So then I was looking through like who's in the tournament and it was like the majority of the well known pro players were already like snagged.
Because so... I was like...
So I messaged Fun because I didn't see Fun on the list.
I was like, hey Fun, like do you have...
Like are you in this tournament and he's like no...
Like Fun FPS.
And um... and he's like...
I was like... yeah...
He's like, oh no, no, like and I was like, do you want to do it?
And he's like, oh sure.
Yeah, it's like okay.
And I was like, can you bring a pro player?
I didn't want to look anymore.
I didn't want to fucking look anymore.
I was tired of looking.
I was tired of looking for teammates.
So I was like, do you do you want to bring somebody?
Like, do you know any pro players that's like not taking it?
He's like, well, I have my teammate Reptar.
By the way, for those who don't know Reptar, he's been like, he has been multiple Rank 1 in Apex Legends.
So he's been like, he's been like Rank 1 Apex Predator.
Yes, I've outsourced.
Look, my original teammates couldn't do it.
Tenjin couldn't do it.
I literally had like one other sub that couldn't do it.
So I outsourced.
Okay, I was tired of looking.
I had other things to do like sleeping after WrestleTuber.
So yes, I told I was like, please Fun, do you know anybody?
And then Fun brought Reptar in.
So I practically have like their entire team, but I'm the new I'm the IGL now.
I'm the IGL now.
They're signed to Doki Bird team now.
It's hide and seek man.
How bad can it be?
It's literally hide and seek.
Like how fucked are they?
They just need to hide.
That's all they need to do.
They know the fucking maps better than me.
So they're gonna carry me
Darkblade, thank you the super chat, thank you.
Thank you.
Sorry mate you mixed me with someone else not the wrong name also you consider Well I mean, like I knew what you guys, like I just knew your icons You should, darkblade You should have brought a paper and printed out your icon and then I would have recognized that you were Dark Blade I didn't hear the last parts,
are dark but didn't hear the blade parts So I assume you know who they are, okay.
I think I meant Darkwing.
Cause like, you know, Darkwing is real.
In the chat.
So like, you know, my fucking visuals of you guys is your fucking icons.
So you should have printed your icon.
Then I would have not mistaken you.
Darkwing, come back out!
Show your presence to everybody so they'll know I'm not crazy.
We consider it loser bracket next year.
I know it'll be a longer event, but it'll be fun.
Like I said, I talked about this earlier.
Darkblade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But like I said, the reason why I don't know if I want to do a loser bracket is because it would take a really long time.
Especially if we do a loser bracket, we have to cut down on participants.
So like, there's no reason...
Not no reason, but that was the reason why I didn't really want to do...
I was thinking about it for next year.
But like...
And I was like worried.
That...
Worried that like...
Having a loser bracket will mean we have to have less participants joining in.
Because it'll be way too long.
Now I'm thinking of the super chat.
Thank you.
Off topic, but have you decided whether you're going to go to EVO?
Thinking of the super chat.
Thank you.
It's a secret.
Kaz, thinking of the super chat.
Thank you.
You'll know after EVO.
After EVO is over.
If I was there or not.
Because then if after EVO is over maybe there'll be a stream...
Maybe there's going to be a waiting room.
That'll be like, whoa, my story is from EVO.
But if there's no waiting room after EVO, then you know I wasn't there.
Or I could have a waiting room for it.
And then I just make up stories.
Oh, I should just do that.
Or maybe I'll just make up stories.
You'll never know!
You'll never know if it's true or not!
The misdirect... It's not paywad because it'll be a stream!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm not the same person I was two icons ago.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I know I wrote down some... How is it gatekeeping?
Streams are free!
I'm sorry, my gatekeeping is while you're internet?
How the fuck is that gatekeeping if it's fucking free?
Alright, let me... I wrote down stuff.
Is there anything else that I...
That I missed out on?
Let's see.
No, I think that's really everything I want to talk about.
For WrestleTuber.
And like Anime North and everything.
Oh yes!
Merch!
Merch is free!
Merch stuff.
Okay.
Like we can get a lot of emails.
I talked about this in the member stream.
I'm gonna make an official post on Twitter soon.
Um... Official post on Twitter soon.
But regarding merch stuff, like the debut merch stuff.
And the Lunar New Year.
We finally have a distributor.
We finally got a distributor.
But!
The distributor is coming over to pick up the stock.
Like next week.
And by then...
Um...
Shipment of stuff...
Would start, I believe, middle of next month?
Middle of June.
I know we're a little bit like delayed regarding shipment and merch stuff.
But now that we have a distributor finally...
Um...
I think maybe this time like...
Like, you know, shipping for stuff would be a lot better now.
So there won't be like future delays.
I hope.
So I hope by now, like now that we have finally settled on a distributor...
Um...
Things will not be delayed as much for future merch release.
I'm still not releasing any new merch yet.
Only because I am waiting...
Like I said, I'm not gonna release any new merch...
Until like the distrib...
Shipment of old merch is situated.
That's why nothing has been released.
No new products have been released.
I do have like new product plans and stuff.
But like I haven't put it out just cause I don't wanna...
You know...
Prom...
Like I don't wanna have like so much stuff promised.
And then like just...
You know, I don't want you guys to like wait for like 500 orders that never like...
Uh...
Arrived.
Um...
That's why.
Like I don't care.
Like I talked about this before.
But like if I had like, you know, merch releases every month or so...
That would have been like 60 to 70% of my income.
Like legitimately...
I would make so much more money off of merch release...
Versus like...
Streaming.
If I had consistent merch release.
But like I'd rather have everything fucking figured out.
And have all the stuff situated when it comes to...
When it comes to...
Like you know, making sure everybody's getting their stuff.
And everybody is getting their shipping.
And everything.
Before I fucking release anything.
Uh...
Next thing...
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
I'm so happy you and Min are talking andoki.
Thank you for putting on this super fun event.
I've had this much fun in ages.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
I'm glad you guys have been...
Uh...
Have enjoyed it so much.
Um...
What else do I want to say?
But yes.
But I'm still going to be packaging stuff on members.
Uh...
So you might get like exclusive like signed card.
Being like...
You know...
You got...
Your merch was packaged by me.
Because you know...
The distributor isn't coming until like next week.
So...
Um...
I still have a lot of time.
To...
You know...
Fucking send out my own stuff.
You know?
I still want to be sure to like be able to send things to you guys.
Those who are waiting.
Um...
That's why I'll be packaging stuff in members.
Uh...
For those who have been waiting for a while.
Um...
And I know like some...
Actually some...
Some dragoons have actually received the Doki Gacha.
They've been posting it on Twitter and stuff.
So...
Congratulations!
You've won the Doki Gacha!
Uh...
Yay!
I still have like Lunar New Year stuff too.
But Lunar New Year will mostly be...
Um...
Because we're still waiting on the pillow...
The Lunar New Year merch.
We're actually still waiting on the pillows.
Um...
At the moment the pillows and the acrylic stands.
So...
I only have the stickers and the buttons.
The stickers, buttons and the red pockets.
From the Lunar New Year merch.
So like...
Uh...
I have...
Like I know like some people have been receiving their Lunar...
Some people have actually received their red pockets already too.
Um...
Because some of it has been shipped out.
So yeah.
Um...
But I have everything from the debut merch.
I have all the stock for debut merch.
So I can ship those out.
Uh...
Ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba...
Oh have you guys seen the postcard?
From...
Okay let me...
Okay I'm just...
Show like...
The...
The limited edition exclusive...
It's gonna be like a little snapshot too.
But let me show you guys.
Uh...
Ba ba ba...
Let me see if I can find it.
I need to do like a really bad quality of this.
Cause it's...
It's exclusive.
Uh...
Let me see if I can find it.
I saved it here somewhere.
Where did I save it?
Oh here it is.
Okay I need to make sure.
Okay here.
I'm gonna make sure it's like super...
Tiny and bad quality.
Alright this is super tiny.
Cause I don't...
I don't have it water marked.
There we go.
I'll make it tiny.
You can't steal this now!
Cause I don't have it water marked cause I'm fucking lazy.
Maybe I should make it tiny.
Yeah you can't steal this.
It's too late.
So this is the postcard and the...
Uh...
Yeah but you can't do anything with it!
Cause it's so tiny!
Right clicking it.
No!
You can't right click it if I fucking move it around!
You can't right click this!
Okay.
Anyway...
Um...
Anyway this is the postcard and the snapshot.
So...
Okay I'll make it a little bit bigger.
What the...
Pause!
Um...
But this is...
This is the...
Basically what the postcard slash snapshot looks like.
Well the snapshot would be like a more zoom in version of this.
Um...
But the people who bought the limited edition bundle with the postcard.
That's what it looks like.
And also like the snapshot in the debut bundle.
Like it's gonna be like you know cropped into like a little snapshot thing.
Like you know this is like...
This is gonna be zoomed in a bit more.
And it looks like a photo and stuff like that.
So that's what it looks like.
Uh...
That's drawn by Poki!
One of my good artist friends.
Um...
Poki is the...
Uh...
Next time I'll have a watermark.
Okay?
I was really lazy.
So...
I didn't...
I was...
Next time it'll be watermarked!
So do not steal!
Uh...
I will have a copyright in wa...
Well not a copyright cause then I'd be lying.
Cause I don't...
I don't have a copyright on it.
So...
I'd be lying if I put like...
Cop...
Like a copy...
Like Doki Bird copyrighted or something.
But next time!
Next time!
It'll be different!
Next time I'll have it watermarked!
So you can't steal it!
Woo!
That's future Doki's problem!
Not current Doki problem!
Um...
But yes.
Uh...
I think that is everything I wanted to update you guys about life.
I'm sorry this wasn't a longer stream.
Um...
I'm very tired.
But...
I hope you guys enjoyed this little life update that we have today.
And...
Uh...
And it was a great time talking to you guys.
I had a great time hanging out with all you guys.
And just...
Let...
Give you guys like...
Just like...
You know...
An insight into what the fuck was going on in Doki's brain when it comes to WrestleTuber.
And...
Oh my god it was so much work.
It was so...
It was so much.
I...
Like...
Like you know the Discord, the info...
It was just me typing like thousands of words.
Like trying to make sure everything was organized and everything.
And making sure like everything was okay.
And guiding...
Like I...
After every day I had like a schedule for like a week.
Like I had a schedule for the casters.
Like each day I had a schedule for the casters and the wrestlers.
To be like...
Okay you guys show up.
Wrestlers you have to show up at this time.
Um...
You have to show up this time.
And bracket two you show up this time.
Bracket three you show up...
This will be the estimated time to show up.
Casters!
We are rotating casters and this is how the castering rotation will be going.
Like these two casters will be here.
These two casters will be casting these matches.
These casters will be casting these matches.
And then it was like we...
I had to like figure out the plan.
And everything.
And oh my god.
It was...
I...
The one thing I forgot to do was show the gamer subcodes for everybody.
For all...
Like some of the participants.
Because I was like...
Oh you guys have a gamer subcode.
Because I didn't want to be like...
Use my...
Only my code.
You know?
Or gamer subs.
Like I know gamer subs sponsored it.
But like you know we had some wrestlers there that also had gamer subcodes.
So I was like you guys show me your gamer subcodes.
And then like I'll show it too.
I was like...
Oh I'm gonna put it so other people can use your codes.
Um...
And um...
I didn't want to like you know just be like...
Oh just use my code.
Because like you know they gave up their time and everything.
And I forgot to put it on stream.
That's why I tweeted it out.
Because I...
I forgot to...
I forgot to put it on stream.
So...
So yeah I was like whoops.
But like...
Because I really appreciate them giving up their time you know.
Their time to do all of this.
And their time to um...
Um...
Their time to uh...
To participate in WrestleTuber.
Because it is a big commitment.
And like for those who are part of the tournament.
You wouldn't know like...
You wouldn't know like you know like when they had to leave.
So they have to make their entire schedule open.
You have to make your entire day open.
Because you don't know when you're supposed to leave.
Like when you're done.
Because like you know those who are part of the tournament.
They don't know if they're gonna make it to day two.
So they have to make sure their entire schedule for day two was uh...
Was opened you know.
So there was that.
And like a huge shout out to everybody for participating.
And for um...
Just like leaving their schedule that open.
I just remember something I forgot to say about the Yuusan thing.
So like yeah.
Yuusan like messaged when we announced it.
Because I didn't tell anybody what the announcement was.
And those that were invited.
So like Yuusan found out about WrestleTuber the moment I announced it.
And then they sent me a message in support too.
And they're like oh my gosh like...
Uh Doki like I'm so proud of you for organizing this.
And then I was like you know what Yuusan.
You have to be there.
You have to be a surprise guest Yuusan.
Like...
You have to be a surprise guest.
And like to be like the...
The fucking coming in with the steel chair.
The classic WWE twist.
Um because Yuusan at first was like...
Didn't...
Was like not didn't want to do it.
But like they were worried that they would fuck it up type deal.
They were worried that they wouldn't be able to...
Um do it in a way that people would like...
Would like enjoy it.
From about...
I was like no it'll be so good Yuusan.
It'll be so funny.
Because it's such a classic WWE twist.
Um yeah.
Yuusan was my Batista.
So I...
Batista.
So I was just like no you have to do it.
It'll be so fucking funny Yuusan.
Like trust me people are gonna love it.
And then Yuusan like showed me like...
Oh I could use like this person.
And like have a video.
And have this rigged and everything.
I was like oh my god perfect.
And they were like the one...
You see I was supposed to only have one surprise guest.
And it was just gonna be Yuusan.
And then obviously like the last minute stuff came up.
So we had three surprise guests.
So like huge shout out to Yuusan for...
For doing all of that.
For the...
For the finals.
And they...
That they...
You know they fucking did...
It was perfect.
It was...
Like Yuusan was not supposed to kick Benno's ass that fast.
Cause like...
Literally I told the person who made the You Man model.
To like...
It had to be the same as everybody else.
So like...
Benno could have won that.
Because the stats were the same.
And...
I don't know how the fuck he got destroyed so fast.
And like literally died.
I don't know how he fucking just died.
Like outside the ring.
People were like...
It was a count out.
He's not supposed to lose his championship belt.
They were gonna...
Like he was gonna keep his belt anyway guys.
But for the sake of the storyline.
We like...
Joked that he lost his belt.
Like...
He did lose the...
The title.
Like...
He's still a loser.
Because he lost to Yuusan.
So...
Like you can't be like...
He's not a winner.
Because he still fucking died.
Like...
He still...
He still fucking died.
You can't call him a winner.
If he just dies.
Like...
But anyway...
Anyway...
I like how someone was like...
He's always been my loser.
Quote affectionate.
But...
But he gets a...
He still gets a belt.
He...
He still gets a belt guys.
Oh...
Anyway...
That was great.
You can't be a winner if you're dead.
Exactly.
He's looking like in the hospital right now.
Fucking...
We're waiting for him to wake up from his coma.
We're just waiting for him to wake up from the coma guys.
Like...
Thoughts and prayers for him at the hospital.
Um...
I was so angry.
But glad that he got the belt.
Like...
Yeah...
It was so like...
It was so like all fun and games.
Like...
He is the...
He...
We can say that he is like...
The...
Tournament...
Tournament winner.
But not the WrestleTuber winner.
I feel like that's the best way to describe it.
He won the tournament.
But Yuusong was the...
The event boss.
The final boss.
So he wasn't the...
The WrestleTuber champion.
He was the tournament champion.
But not the WrestleTuber champion.
Yeah.
When you win the battle.
But lost the war.
The secret final boss.
Yeah.
The people's champ.
He was the people's champ.
Um...
Anyway.
Adam.
You met his WrestleTuber guy.
Um...
Anyway.
That was...
It was great.
Uh...
I had a great time.
Um...
With everything that happened.
Next week will definitely be a chill week for me.
I'm gonna relax and...
Uh...
I'm gonna relax next week.
But this week is still...
It's still working time.
It's still Doki Bird workout.
Um...
Thank you for all the super chat everybody.
I really...
I really appreciate it guys.
Also, I actually had like people in the comments being like the game glitched.
Billion was supposed to win that.
But like what happened was that apparently Beto made his wrestler incredibly dishonest.
So like he would purposely rig the matches.
And apparently so when you saw we saw him like took those like things down on the ring.
Um...
The reason why the referee wasn't there.
Was because like the game didn't glitch.
The referee turned his back to fix the ring.
And because he turned his back to fix the ring.
That was the exact moment that Billion pinned Beto.
So Beto got a free...
Freebie there.
That was actually...
Beto's AI wrestler was fucking insane.
Like I don't know.
Like I feel like...
Like I felt like the Beto AI was self-aware.
There's no...
Like...
I'm...
I felt like the Beto AI evolved to be self-aware.
To the point where that's why he fucking died.
He gained...
He gained sentience.
Cause like...
Like he was...
He did okay.
For the entire tournament.
And then...
And like he did Beto things.
And then like he continued to do Beto things when he fucking died.
Like...
And he ended up losing the cup.
So...
It was actually crazy.
I...
I don't know how the fuck that fucking AI become...
Become...
Beto 3.0...
Basically...
So...
The AI was literally just Beto.
Perfectly accurate Beto.
Yeah...
It was actually insane how...
How well the AI perfectly...
Reply...
I'm gonna call it here guys.
Thank you everybody for the super chats.
Thank you all for like hanging out with me today and chilling with me.
Guys, I really appreciate it.
I'm tired.
So I'm gonna take another nap.
But it was great talking to you guys and just giving you guys insight about like what was going on with like everything.
Like you know how the rest of the tube area was done and all that stuff.
Again, like a huge shout out to everybody that participated, to the staff, to the staff that was there and everything.
I really appreciate all the people that were there for long hours.
Doing like the announcement, like announcing, casting.
Just you know, fucking improv-ing a lot of stuff.
Huge shout out to the guest casters too.
We actually got a real WWE, like an ex-WWE person doing one of the guest casting.
If you guys didn't know.
We got Mace from WWE guest casting for us.
And maybe, I hope in WrestleTube 2025.
I hope we can get another WWE person on the show.
I feel like that would be so cool.
And honestly, they need the ring.
I mean, they need the ratings.
Okay, that's fucked up for me to say.
Anyway...
Wow!
The Slant!
If they target the Weebs, they'll get more people watching!
They got to expand their fucking network, guys!
The Slant!
You know the ratings are falling, guys.
You fucking know.
You don't fucking lie to me.
I saw people shit-talking about how the ratings are falling.
So I'm just saying, WWE.
My email is dokiiknread at gmail.com.
So you want to reach out and like, you know, I don't know, sponsor or send somebody over for next year?
Bro, this new target demographic.
You haven't targeted the Weebs yet, guys.
You haven't targeted the VTuber fans.
Just think!
You can convert a whole new audience!
No, stop!
Doki is at an all-time high!
All I'm saying...
Anyway, guys...
Uh...
I had a great time, everybody.
As always, everyone, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around.
To get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys!
Bye!